hello I'm Gavin I'm Dan we're the slow
mo guys it's June do it no that means I
do giant balloons although this one's
all skanky is about a year old I think
being in the shed since last June we're
going to got enough for just one video
this June I'm not gonna do a full month
but I was recently watching the original
giant balloon video which has over 117
million views at the time of recording
and there was a GoPro looking down and I
thought landing on a balloon and seeing
it from above would look very cool well
you're right but now it means you're
gonna have to film the slow-mo and I'm
gonna be the one jumping I've had enough
of jumping from Heights recently yeah
just finished breaking my wrist jumping
into some just got done with that yeah
finish with that so you'll be up the
ladder yeah hopefully only breaking the
balloon not your wrist and I'll be on
the roof hopefully not breaking the
camera or my legs that's that's the plan
it's a tall order this one I really hope
we don't break anything
everything here we are again I'm
actually kind of looking forward to
being splash to this it's really warm
buddy you're in it yeah so this is our
standard procedure red 6-footer I didn't
think that in 2010 we'd be doing these
in 2018 neither did I you think you
would have been doing something
different with your life yes hopefully
this cushions you enough to not hit the
ground beneath yeah hopefully you want
me to swan dive I feel like if you swan
dive that's spreading your weight more
evenly then what then like hitting your
legs on it you but your legs are
supposed to go first you don't ever like
knowing no one you go to gymnastics go
my land chin first and then and finish
the vault with a swan dive onto the
floor but think about it if you're
landing on something soft than uneven
don't really want to land on your ankles
I would say so we've sort of learnt that
when you fill one of these the weight of
the water sort of crushes a lot of the
slack underneath leaving the top to
become very tight so we thought it was a
good idea to massage the balloon and you
can actually feel and hear it like
creaking when you do it
you can hear that slice you're just
adding some of its slack just adding
some slack to the top rather than the
bottom bite oh it's like weird cuz the
beside moves around like good yeah every
time I do it I'm no this is my nervous
face looks pretty nervous when you're up
there cuz I'm six foot tall
if I'm an eight foot ladder it makes it
really high I don't think this is a six
foot balloon it certainly looks like
it's filling up like at the neck which
means it's almost full to capacity
it looks extra bloated but it's not very
I swear the one I jumped from spread
wider maybe it's cuz it's been in the
shed since June yeah pass it to me yeah
yeah B not a good start if you fall
grab on to the gutter will definitely
break that should slow you down just
enough great chase me okay I'm good I
head back down what did you do today oh
you know just climbed out on my roof and
dangled a high-speed cinema camera while
some other bloke jumped on a balloon
you're a B yeah
that was that you're right yeah I went
for it
winded myself when I landed because it
was kind of like belly flopping but not
because your belly flop and you just go
oh and then it burst it felt like I
landed with Shh
see it was kind of like landing on a on
a fats cushion of water
Ripple's Wow the half that balloons
burst by the time the other half people
realized like it forgets and then I
think the pressure that you forced into
the side that hasn't burst then splits
right down the middle face down I was
winded by that I like the spread of the
water it's perfectly even you haven't
got a shot of that before it's
completely from above and totally see
and spread there are you moving it
here's me pressing the deer the trigger
and trying not to fall off the roof so a
lot of time whenever we just have one
phantom going I like to get a couple of
times from multiple focal lengths like I
like to get the wide first you know make
sure we've got it
yeah then go in for a nice close-up and
if I botch the focus you know it's not a
big deal because we already got the wide
I like it so that means you have to do
again yep I'm actually ok with it
because it is really hot out here and
I'm nice and refreshed you're probably
sweating up there on the roof I tell you
what an amazing time it's very hot on
the knees yes like straddling it my
knees were burning out there I should
have got some sort of handheld
accessories but you're right ok
[Music]
you slid quite a long way
I was very surprising this was filming
like this but you slid so far so
actually had to track you because it
that's the hell of a move being on the
roof been like improvising track that
it's off your s lovely bald spot down on
there Friar Tuck action almost identical
way of falling there as well yeah you've
definitely found your way and then it's
slow it split from around the edge and
came up to me that's a weird one I
thought that you've seen that before you
see on this one I pretty much just hit
the floor and the balloon sort of got in
the way from the first one it felt like
almost like cushioned me and then let me
go is much more comfortable this one was
just sort of like bang if I speed this
one up you can see how far you slid
followed as with any sudden release of
War you cause like a flood effect a
sudden damaging effect and we've managed
to wash away all the topsoil from around
the tree just in one hit completely just
gone
yeah it's Texas to the partly the water
anyway well to make up for this I've not
run the sprinklers for the last 18
months should enjoy that do you mean the
sprinklers you bought specifically to
just do a prank on me and then never use
yes oh yeah why did it's well the
sprinklers already there the controller
I specifically bought okay I love you
like I've got an automated house with
sprinklers never use them there and
there's no point wasting water it's
actually true you just did that that
wasn't a waste though that was that
because we a watered plants be it was
fun
so while we were just making this video
we received delivery of this which
because this comes out in June the
audience has already seen in a lot of
videos we're about to make but for us we
just got it
so we're gonna use it it will do 12 and
a half thousand three second HD so I
don't think I've ever seen a giant
balloon pops this way no I definitely
haven't are you gonna do this one on the
roof or new no not moving this from the
roof well I just don't think it's gonna
add a lot from the roof I'm gonna I want
to see it pop around the sides three two
one it's fully cushioned me and I love
it again oh I got like a right slap on
my side there oh I don't know how well I
got that
[Music]
yeah we've only got blue left which
matches the blue tarp which is kind of
inconvenient actually I should suffice
looks like the balloons like an
extension of the tarpaulin yeah just
like bouncing slightly and then landed
in it broke this time I went straight
[Music]
that look quite refreshing already was
yeah I'm nice and fresh now you must be
nice and hot I am hot it was very hot
upon the rear and I didn't break
anything very happy with that I'm also
happy I didn't slip through the roof and
fall into the house yeah although
holding a phantom that would have been
an interesting piece of footage you
should have done this if you land it you
just got like drinking it yeah hopefully
you enjoyed that lovely giant boolean
video feel free to follow us on the
various social medias it's all in the
description it's true yeah more
Instagram boys these days not that we
post any more than on Twitter by that we
mean we post once every like a month go
get better I know we're not very good
better at social media bear at YouTube
we're just terrible but follow us anyway
right we also have a second channel and
it's a pretty sweet prank that I did to
Dan with the diamond play button Oh
where'd yeah alright we'll see you in
the next video